you read an interesting article about
the ice cream machine at mcdonald's oh
yeah they're doing a deep dive into this
yeah so the ftc is like sending letters
to owners of franchises yeah we don't
know where covid came from but we're
doing a deep dive
into why the ice cream machines at
mcdonald's seem to be broken more often
than when they're working
the priorities are skewed
mcdonald's said in a statement to the
globe that the company quote has no
reason to believe we are the focus of an
ftc investigation the company said it
has a team working on the ice cream
issue the ice cream issue
and it is deploying solutions
such as new training for employees in
regular maintenance checkup on the
machines
we've been at mcdonald's a lot yeah at
night and what happens they usually say
the machine is down and a lot of them
say it's for cleaning
but we know that's not the case some of
them are honest and go we don't know why
it's down
it's like uh during the power grid
failures uh uh uh when gray davis was
the governor of california oh yeah yeah
enron was just forcing the power grids
to go down uh to jack the price of power
up this is kind of what's happening at
mcdonald's they force the machine to go
down
um on a smaller scale but maybe not i
don't know
and uh my problem with mcdonald's and
this is with a lot of things by the way
it's not only mcdonald's a lot of the
whether it's a mcflurry or a blizzard or
a concrete anything where it has ice
cream and then candy mixed through it
and you could tell me if i'm wrong when
i grew up the candy was swirled through
the entire
thing
now it is best case the top 25 are
toppings the bottom is ice cream
and i don't know why that is
one of the one of the creepiest things
i've ever seen the mcflurry machine was
broken and uh i was in pennsylvania i
had done a show years ago and i stopped
into a rest stop mcdonald's
which means it's a mcdonald's but
there's also bathrooms for the truckers
to
and then there's get some head
and then there's also like a gift shop
for i don't know
like a postcard that says pennsylvania
um
and it's for human traffickers and
people that need to take a piss
and i walked in i ordered a mcflurry and
they didn't have one so she hand
flurried it
she took this spoon
and just like in front of you she just
she just and she this is what was spooky
she never broke eye contact with me
while she was hand flouring it as if to
say this is my life
she just locked eyes with me and it was
an oreo mcflurry
and and and she just was like stabbing
it with the spoon
and
and i and it was a good 30 seconds
of
unbroken eye contact with this uh
monster really
and she was just kind of flurrying it by
hand and then she just put it on the
counter
and walked away
i don't know if that was like the lowest
point in her life or if that if she was
angry that i ordered a mcflurry or
i don't get it i don't understand it but
that's something i remember
but people are getting angry
uh at mcdonald's because people have had
enough
the things that we really
we demand in this country are
interesting at issue could be the
relationship mcdonald's has with taylor
commercial food service a company that
makes most of its ice cream machines the
journal reported that the machines which
make milkshakes soft serve ice cream and
the mcflurry require a quote nightly
automated heat cleaning cycle that can
last up to four hours to destroy
bacteria
if that process doesn't work owners must
call a technician before they can use
the machine so there is some science
behind the answer that it's down for a
cleaning
so the science is that they're trying to
destroy the bacteria in the ice cream
machine so it's up for 20 hours and then
down for four and then it should be back
up for another 20
every day on a cycle but it should be
down but see a lot of mcdonald's on 24
hours oh yeah that's right so you know
sometimes the four hours it's down it's
like 11 12 i mean i'm like hey man
what are we doing this is prime time
this is prime time for the mcflurry but
people don't care
people don't give a [ __ ] there was
another scene in the demilio thing where
they were eating hibachi now you like
hibanji i like him i've never in my life
had fun at a hibachi place it's kind of
fun to go out is it fun the they do the
volcano with the onion you don't find it
a little demoralizing
that the chef has to do that i think he
likes it he likes making a volcano out
of onions some of them seem cheery when
they do it they like doing the flips
with a lot of people seem cheery when
they're doing things that they hate
i don't like it because the number one
the food none of it's good true none of
it's when you get the food you go ah
it's overcooked shrimp
that was thrown in the air yes it's not
good yeah i also don't like
that
there's people excited
about
like the guy doing tricks with uh rice
and onions and it's odd to me and i hate
the way you all sit
like it's a show it feels like you're at
sea world watching like the
the sea lions
but you like that that's something about
it you you like you get to sometimes you
get to meet an interesting couple from
across the table
at the hibachi yeah yeah what do you
consider interesting what are you and
your wife considering well okay god help
us i think the last time i went out in
austin to a hibachi grill which was one
time there was a guy that was uh filming
the guy do the choo choo train what the
hell is the choo choo try so what they
do is they have the you know if anyone
said to me you want to go to bocce i
would not i would like
take them out of my phone
i would delete their number it's just
the most like
a basic [ __ ] like to me saying like
i wanna like it would be like
it would be it's it's this bad right
yeah yeah you're going to dinner with
someone to go hey why don't we go
instead of dinner they go like this they
go why don't we go to a homeless shelter
tonight and i'll help out
like you get that text in the car you go
what you don't know how to respond right
you don't want to do it
but you
you can't just be like hey [ __ ] that
but that's the hibachi text you're like
oh let's do hibachi go
hey man no
i don't want to do that
so you met a guy that was in the choo
choo train is what again
uh so you know how they usually do the
volcano with smoke coming out yeah we
know sometimes they have the uh train
whistle which is those long wooden
whistles when you blow through it it
sounds like a train whistle yes and then
he moves it to make it look like a train
is going and usually the little kids
start you know they like it but this a
grown man was just filming it with his
phone i don't want to go to any
restaurant where children are uh happy
i never want to see a happy child at a
restaurant i want to see miserable
children sitting there
angry but now you have the technology
just give him the phone put the kid on
the phone yeah yeah put the kid on the
phone a big ipad let the kid figure out
who they are and what they believe while
you have dinner
you don't need to entertain the kids
with hibachi anymore do kids even like
hibachi they just want to be on [ __ ]
gaming and [ __ ] they want the shirley
temple and then the rice and you pour
all the ginger sauce on it that's what
ugh
it sounds
heinous
it's never good dude the food is never
good when you the food at habanshi place
when you get it
it's kind of like you feel like
like you're refugee
it's like rice and over cup cooked
shrimp and like an onion that's how they
feed it to you at the end they throw the
shrimp into your mouth yeah i don't want
that where everyone opens their mouth
like birds
and then he goes around and i don't want
that
someone could choke to death like that
that's an at-risk activity